Les amis! Bonsoir ou bonjour
j'espère bonsoir pour que vous ayez bien peur
et bienvenue dans ce dernier épisode d'Outlast mon gars
on vas enfin savoir où est Lynn, qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé
qu'est ce qui est arrivé à Jessica dans le passé
C'est parti
Olala mais quelle intro exeptionnelle
donc souvenez vous on était suspendu à ce rebord
et euh il faudrait qu'on y, qu'on descende
mais j'sais pas comment faire
HA, voila ok j'ai trouvé
INCROYABLE
Il pleut toujours du sang
voila une météo euuh
très peu charmante
*rire*
*bruit de portes*
D'accord j'rigole mais pas trop non plus
j'allais dire une blague mais j'ai plus du tout envie
avec cette porte qui "vibre" toute seule
ça me fait plus du tout envie
vraiment on n'a pas envie de rigoler, c'est fini
faut qu'je saute en face
ah c'est horrible la porte dans mon dos bouge, faut qu'je saute en face AH !
damn it
WHAT !
WHAT ! Mais c'est quoi cette mini porte ?
c'est même pas une porte ça
ah faut qu'j'aille au dessus ok
ah putin j'suis encore dans ces endroits mais non c'est rempli de ...
d'héré... de sales hérétiques
qui me ...
qui me font extrêmement ... Peur
Oh putain
Oh mec ça a fait un max de bruit
La ça va j'suis moins euh
la dernière fois j'étais très fatigué dans le le le
l'épisode 5 euh
donc j'étais vraiment euh je flippais pour rien
La ça va un peu mieux en vrai
je je prends du recul par rapport aux choses
par rapport à ma vie
Holy shit
Oh putaiiiin
ah mais merde
oh les gars vous êtes pas cool, ah mais merde
ah ouais bah ouais
ah j'me suis trompé d'chemin
mais j'ai pris du recul sur ma vie donc ça va aller mieux
AAAAAAAAH   WTF
WTF
*bruits étranges* je rampe
*bruits chelou*
est ce que vous pouvez me laisser tranquille genre une minute svp
une minute
le temps qu'j'me soigne
nooon c'est mort on peut que courir
OUUUH AH !
on y va on y va on y va
Alleeez
et là  on va re atterrir  dans le ... la putain d'école j'suis sûr
derrière ça
ah non c'est faux c'est entiérement faux
c'est quoi ça ?
ha ok il ferme la (trape) ... ok
alors on se soigne
on se bande toujours le bras gauche
*rire*
vous êtes nombreux à avoir bloqué sur ça
c'est vrai qu'c'est marrant le mec s'fait mal partout
mais il soigne que l'bras gauche
ok on y va
oh mec
va falloir monter
oh ... HOLALA
pourquoi y avait 2 bandages d'un coup mec j'crois qu'on avait jamais vu ça encore
de tout le jeu on n'a jamais vu ça
euh sssss ... c'est pas forcément bon signe
comment ça "il arrive"
ah leee le télésiège
la cabine
ouoooh
*bruit*
OUOOOH !
oh mais c'est putain
non pardon la j'avoue non j'avoue la j'ai pas fait  assez  le point sur ma vie
j'ai pas pris assez  de recul
*rire*
j'me suis chié  d'sus
aller on y va on y va on y va ... mmmh c'est parti
ah merde
on y va on y va on a pas peur on a pas peuuur
laissez-nous tranquille
Live us alone
direction les mines
n'importe quoi direction on on cherche en fait la elle est où Lynn parce qu'on est  aux mines là
j'saute dans le vide hein
aaah (aïe)
ah
oh putain mais il fait quoi lui en plein milieu
OH PUTAIN mais mec y sont ...
j'suis revenu au début ?
ça dégage
ça dégage !
et c'est le mec qui doublait la voix des monstres
que le nain sur son ... sur sa monture
c'est le même grain de voix putain
voila p'tite anecdote nulle  ah ben ça y est les mines
putain voilà  là  on y est vraiment
mais oui Jess c'est fini, Jess elle est OUT, elle est OUT of the game
putaiiin ouaaah comme on s'enfonce mec
on va bien pouvoir rien faire ci on est dans le caca
alors qui sont les gens des mines, est ce que ce sont des gens charmants
oh putain
AAAH ?
Ah Ah Ah ?
Lynn mon amour
ch'arrive
le mec est  mort dix fois normalement en vrai ... EN VRAI
putain encore ça va encore s'remettre à redescendre d'un coup
non?
ah c'est bon
WHAT ?
non mais j'fais d'la merde c'est pas du tout ça qu'il faut faire... AH si c'est ça ok
PUTIN !?!
alors on a quoi ?
ah bah on vas devoir passer en dessous
comme ça
et hop la voilaaa
mais au moins on est en bas mec
on n'a plus qu'a escalader la p'tite cloture
saloprie, putin le screamer audio
bon on est bon
oooh putin on est dans les mines mec
*incompréhenssibles*
ok
et bien "welcome to the mines" hein ?
ouaaah, y font péter des ... péter au c4 les ...
la pierres
plutôt que de miner
est-ce que ça existe vraiment
ce délire là
oh putiiin !
my bad
je ... faut toujours suivre le monstre
ou, ou aller
ah j'ai trouvé juste une page
CHAPITRE 11, oh mon dieu
ok
ok ok ok
ouoooh
ah d'accord c'est en train d'se faire manger par des vers, TRES BIEEEN !
donc ne jamais suivre les monstres au final
il t'ammène devant des cadavres
j'arrive Lynn, j'arrive Lynn
j'arrive LYNN
j'suis où la putin ?
p'tin mec je m'y crois trop
faut qu'je descende encore plus mais non mais pire idée, mais non mais non
j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive
oh non
non arrête
arrête, c'est vraiment la pire phrase que j'ai entendu d'ma vie
tu n'aie pas méchant Blake juste désorienté
aaah ! il clignoté j'me disais attends un monstre ça clignote pas
damn it
j'crois qu'ça veut dire qu'c'est bloqué
y avait encore un putin de mec en foetus enchain, sa ça me rends ouf
euh faut faire qoui ? faut remonter ducoup ? on...on a plus d'autres pistes de toutes façons
j'vais pas te mentir
ah on peut prends à gauche ou à droite
à droite
et encore un foetus AH
bon ça c'est une réponse aussi que j'aimerais avoir, c'est à quel moment de l'histoire il est en train de
commenté les vidéos qu'il a prises enfaite c'est quand, c'est quand qu'il y a ça
Holala ils se sont fait exploser
c'est est-ce que ça va être la fin du jeu justement ça va être sa ou j'sais pas
ah ! apparament là on a un petit trou
heuresement que les gens qui passent avant nous saignent énormemmet
ça nous permet vraiment de trouver facilement les chemins à prendre
c'est vrai mec ci y avait pas de sang on aurait jamais trouvé
Oooh oh putin y a mec qui est mort juste là quoi
j'arrive Lynn j'prends un peu mon temps j'suis désolé
*chantonne*
ok
et là c'est quoi
c'est la pire idée du monde d'ouvrir cette porte à votre avis vu qu'ell était vérouillée y a bien une raison
et je l'avais dit *rire*
je l'avasi totalement dis et là le truc c'est qui va falloir aller la où le monstre est apparu
parce qu'c'est toujours comme ça
et vous l'savez mieux qu'moi
ah ouais là c'est un cul de sac donc enfaite faut vraiment aller là-bas quoi
ah il est plus là
on va garder notre sprint
au cas où il se mets à nous courir après
*crie du monstre*
voila exactement comme là exactement comme là
mais exactement comme ça
*a peur*
AAAH !
fils de pute (distcrètement)
mais moi aussi mec
j'suis dans la merde j'suis dans la merde la plus totale j'suis dans la merde la plus totale
j'suis dans la merde la plus totale
et j'parle pas la station essence
hyper marrant
hop la on reviens là où on était, le truc bien nuuul
bon mec faut y allais à un moment
est-ce que c'est l'bon chemin c'est ça la question
est-ce que c'est le bon ch'min
ouiii
ouoooh
j'vais regarder la vidéo dans l'doute
R.I.P. attends mais le mec Jessica enfaite c'était l'amour de ta vie et tu t'es rabattu sur Lynn ou quoi mec
c'est trop bizarre comment il parle
wtf ok à droite j'ai compris j'ai compris
oh putin non on redescend
oui j'espéré qu'se soit ouvert
ci s'était ouvert mec on était mort hein j'annonce
on était foutu
on était "Dead by Daylight" vous aurais compris le jeu de mots exeptionnel
alors
on y va
t'façon la mec y a rien à faire clairement faut y aller
et "vamos"
on sait qu'faut monter et aller à droite
voila et faut l'faire sortir
jusque là-bas
ok et maintenant
et alors
par là ?
ah ok y a un éguillage y a un éguillage, j'ai compris
aller aller
ci ça arrive sur moi la on est d'accord on j'suis foutu on peut riren faire
ok
c'est fait
oh le petit trou mon pote YES
damn it ... on est bien
oh nooon
non
arrêtez avec ce mec arrêtez il me fout l'cafard
faut aller où là non clairement pas faut aller là-bas
oh y a une page
et un mort embroché
*lis un peu*
D'ACCORD
d'accord d'accord d'accord
euh Lynn
mon amour
la j'commence à craqué psycologiquement mon amour, j'annonce
j'ai est vraiment marre
il faut allait où là ?
faut aller par là au final dans le p'tit trou, AH BEH OUIII MEC
au final putin
ouoooh
mec faudrait qu'on soit ultra chanceux pour trouver une pile dans cette putin de mine quoi !
qu'est-ce qu'ça foutrait là réellement
vous en faites pas j'en ai encore en stock
p'tin ils font tout péter en vrai
ok
on y va
ouaaah ça s'intensifie de ouf oh non attends j'recharge avant d'rencontrer un monstre
ok
alors
y a des casques ouais bon bah allons-y mec
putin il est temps de voir Lynn la vraiment
oh non putiiin
*cris chelous*
ça venait de la le son y venait d'là
wtf
Lynn
tu me manques baby
j'aimerais télement te retrouver
ça fais 5h qu'je joue dans ce but
oh putin oh putin arrêtez me faîtes pas chier aller ... non
oh putin faut rejoindre euh ...
ah
ah !?! pas d'chance *rire*
ok "vamos"
oh putin mais elle me cours après la pute
OH MY GOOOOOSH
let's run
oh merde j'me suis trompé d'chemin j'ai trop pas de chance
*rire*
WHAT !
c'est la fin pour moi ?
ah non c'est bon
et m'suis toujours j'l'entends j'annonce
j'préfère vous l'dire, j'préfère être franc avec vous
Arrêteeer
arrêtre vous m'foutez le cafard
ah mais c'est par où putin
c'est un vrai labyrhinte la c'est eau
c'est par là
damn it c'est pas là c'est pas dutout là qui a dit que c'était là
enfin en vrai c'est par là mais c'est qu'elle nous a québlo
va falloir la brain comme ça on la brain on est en train d'la brain
attends faut lui non on lui a pas laisser le temps d'faire le tour
faut lui laisser le temps d'venir voila et maintenant ony va
et la on la brain
parce qu'on est hyper malin
*rire*
aller remonte à la surface à un moment aussi
ok
la faut allez par là
aller mets toi...cours putin il a plus de souffle le con
COURS PUTIN oh ça m'rends ouf
genre tes essouflé dans ces moments la mec dans ces moments la j'te jure ta sprint infini mon pote
la stamina ça existe plus pour toi
ah merde attends j'suis revenu au même endroit non non y avait pas de porte
bon j'ai une terrible nouvelle a vous annoncé mais enfaite on est pas dutout la ou il faut *rire*
mec j'ai condanné la porte et tout pour rien mec ça menne nulle part putin
oooh non c'est exeptionnel quoi
on est vraiment des cacas et ci elle est la mec c'est la fin on est foutu bah la c'est la fin du monde
et j'pense qu'elle va être là
ouais bah regarde
la meuf elle campe, elle zone
en vrai faut qu'on meurt j'suis désolé mais faut qu'on ... ouais vas-y tue nous tue nous on s'en sortira pas
oh vous avait vu y a des...des espèces de
ah ouais ouais a bah la elle pris dans un cul de sac ah bah elle m'a bien défoncé l'cul
enfaite y faut faire comme ce qu'on avait fait on avait était génie sur ce move incroyable on l'avait esquivé
mais enfaite fallait pas dutout aller dans la poèce ou j'suis allais
ça s'était vraiment pour les cons et vu qu'suis con j'suis tombé en plein dedans
attends c'est ou déjà j'me souviens plus
la y a un passage ou faudra aller ... ah voila c'est la
j'crois qu'elle arrive de la
souvenez-vous
normalement elle arrive de la
on la voit y a des flammes la bas  la lumière commence a hein
voila elle arrive
quand elle passe
faut qu'on passe la sous l'eau
comme prévu elle est la avec sa couronne de brindilles
très belle couronne
la faut y aller
aller remonte
ici y a un panneau a activé enfaite que j'avais pas vu
voila
enfaite la pièce c'est pour te cacher si elle te grille
mais c'est pas dutout
pour y aller
sans rien y faire
ici y a un autre panneau qu'j'ai vu juste avant d'mourir
ouais j'suis mort 2, 3 fois hein j'annoce
et la ensuite faut y retourner
on va l'esquiver vous en faîtes pas
on est ou la ?
putin
ok c'est la a gauche
ok ... niquel ... on l'a fait les gars
putin ok la faut sauter
YOLO
Aaah putin *rire* mec j'ai tellement eu la haine de l'foirer c'lui la putin quel con
alors
mec on va p't être trouver Lynn un jour quoi
ça serait bien franchement
ça commence à être long la en vrai
est-ce qu'on a pas une pile parce que franchement un jour ou l'autre on va manquer de pile ça va être terrible
*éternu*
wouuuh
alors
ok, on a ce truc là
ok, j'ai compris... éguillage
j'ai rien fais moi à Jessica c'est,c'est toi qu'est-ce que tu lui a fait
c'est toi
ok on y va
Bim !
holalalalalaaa, j'en peux plus de ces visions mec
gauche, tout droit...vas-y tout droit
ok *rire*
la réponse était rapide
ok
échelle
putin mais mec, un jour faut qu'on voit Lynn mais vraiment j'en peux plus
j'trouve ça un peu long en vrai de revoir Lynn
c'est vraiment euh putin
tout l'jeu c'est du Hide and Seek
Oh merde
ah j'ai cru que c'était d'ma faute
oh shit
ok
bon
mmmh
mouiii !
aller laisse moi laisse moi laisse moi laisse moi, laisse moi stp
ah ouais on me suit hein ça y a des flammes derrière ça me suit on va pas s'mentir
ça fait pas semblant... AH j'suis épuisé
est-ce que c'est l'moment d'être épuisé
est-ce que vraiment le moment est propice à l'épuisement
oh merdegauche ou droite
vas-y euh droite
holala, on est lent
elle est juste derrière hein
oh non j'ai plus de pile à ce moment là, c'est serieux ça ?
ok
faut pas qu'on fasse de la merde
vous savez qu'j'ai
une grande faiblesse
OOOH, ah bah oui
ok faut aller vers la lumière
y a... there is light
oh elle me suit putin y a eu un "plouf"
oh putiiin c'est plein d'hérétiques qui sonten train d'tombés mec
c'est sûr
faut pas qu'j'aille là
oh putin c'était par là, holala
je suis obstiné à me dire "non, c'est pas par là, c'est faut"
pourquoi il clignote vert mon écran
quoi !
ah ok y a une échelle c'est bon
oh j'ai cru, j'ai cru que j'm'étais totalement fail
mais on est bon
et heuresement,et dans l'histoire on a trouvé une pile mon gars et ça
ça ça nous a mit très très bien
parce que là les piles on les consommes à une vitesse mon gars
y fait tellement sombre, on est tout le temps avec la caméra ouvert
c'est terrible
bon
est-ce qu'on va revoir un jour notre amie Lynn
notre femme Lynn j'ai envie de te dire même
est-ce que ducoup on sortira ce reportage
parce qu'à la base on était là pour faire un documentaire sur une fille retrouvée morte étranglée sur la route enceinte
c'était la fille de notre 1er ami souvenez vous qui s'est fait tué au bout d'une minute d'amitié
c'est terrible
ah
euuuh ouais
bon bah mec ok
houlalaaa
faut arrêter ça
j'économise un peu de baterie désolé
j'avoue c'est tellement la crise des piles mais bon
ah ok au-dessus
ok... on va recharger  parce qu'on a vraiment plus de... de piles
j'sais pas combien il nous en reste en stock va falloir être prudent
sauvegarde, ah ça sent pas bon, on connais bien
ok
ah une page mon dieu je l'avais pas vu
*lit pas beaucoup*
il faut arrêter
(en rigolant) il faut arrêter vraiment
à chaque fois j'lis une phrase mais au bout d'une phrase j'suis convaincu qu'il faut arrêter de lire ça
ah y a des bruits
est-ce que c'est des...
poison
mais non ... mais elle m'a prit ma caméra au calme
c'est c'est pas normal
déjà quand tu pocket, quand tu voles quelqu'un comme ça à l'arraché
tu lui souffle pas du pollen dans les yeux
pour commencé
c'est un peu moyen...un peu limite comme manière de faire
Oooh !?!
serait-ce la fin du jeu ?
serait-ce Lynn
bah ci l'autre m'avait pas soufflé d'la cocaïne dans l'nez j'pourrais p'têtre venir plus vite
*rire* j'avoue c'est chaud
holala, OH y a... y a Lynn mec
QUOI ? elle a...
j'ai cru qu'elle avait plus de jambe putin
oh
ils sont... c'est la meilleur scène du jeu quoi, elle fait tellement plaisire
vilaine va me traite pas de chiffe molle putin
oh
ah genre on sortait vraiment ensemble, ouais c'est ça enfaite, il sortais vraiment avec Jessica à la base
elle s'est tuée et ça l'a traumatisé à vie
et j'pense que il va y avoir l'histoire de ce...
tu vois genre on est dans un endroit où on a pas le droit d'être et il va nous tomber dessus
ho putin
demander quoi putin
oh shit, comment ça fait "bader" mec d'être dans cette école là
après tout, toutes les visions qu'on a eu mec
c'est l'horreur quoi
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent tous seuls à cette heur là
Oooooh c'est tous les éléments qu'on a vu
mais oui bien sûr
*rire*
c'est mignooon
c'est tellement mignon
ah y a des bruits de pas à droite
putiiin
putiiiiin
putiiin mec
ok
tellement badant
tellement badant mon gars
c'est c'est juste pas croyable
ce grand couloir avec tous les casiers qui est de retour
oh putin j'sais même pas quoi dire tellement j'trouve ça ignoble quoi
il est horrible putin le mec il est horrible
même sa voix il l'on trop bien choisie le doubleur il le fait à merv...
*cris de Jessica*
*cris de détresse de Jessica*
oooh
oooh putin
*cri de Jessica*
*rire*
merde merde moi ça me faisais marrer mais non
il faisait pas ça pour rien le mec putin, oh putin
il était carrément vénère
oh putin mec cette cinématique
incroyable
ça fout le cafard
c'est tellement bien fait les timing et tout, t'arrive dans l'couloir et t'a le père t'a juste le temps dele voir la suivre
AH LE FILS DE PUTE, pardon
ça m'a échapé fallait qu'je le dise
Holalalala
c'est terrible mon gars on est où, on est en enfer clairement c'est l'enfer
ok
putin j'suis content que...
qu'on voit enfin tout ça, enfin content euh
j'suis triste de découvrir ce qu'il s'est passer mais ...
j'suis content de ...
d'enfin après 5h de jeu avoir enfin les réponses à nos questions
ça fait plaisir
putin Lynn
c'est Lynn ? ouais
faut qu'on se casse comme au début du jeu putin
*rire*
il tape des phases mon gars il deviens ouf lui
Oh c'est le soleil qui se lève
Yeah enfin
vous étiez nombreux à vous demander pourquoi il faisait tout le temps nuit
parce qu'enfaite on vient vraiment de vivre une nuit
c'est genre 6h de jeu et c'était vraiment la nuit l'avion y s'est crashé à minuit, là il est 6h du mat
donc le soleil commence enfin à se lever
et c'est pas pour nous déplaire
aller on va s'en sortir Lynn
on va suivre le soleil
putiiin c'est comme au début du jeu quoi
ça va aller Lynn ça va aller ça va aller
c'est quoi quoi ?
Houoooh y a du feu wtf
ça va aller Lynn courage courage
ça va aller ça va aller t'en fait pas
on va être bien on ira à l'hôpital
de St-Boulet les Trous
pour accoucher
ne t'en fait pas
ah merde
pire accouchement du monde
très clairement
on est euh... attends mais la meuf elle est tombée de 2 mètres
ah bah y a un matelas tiens
met toi bien
ça va aller ça va aller ça va aller
oh putiiin mais qu'est-ce qu'elle fait là c'est sa maison à cette femmeou quoi
ohputin elle était là juste à côté mec
ça va aller
ma p'tite dame
ça va aller mais si tout va bien ça va aller
on va t'allonger on va t'allonger juste là y a une psychopathe qui "instant" tuer le bébé ci on fait rien
ça va aller ça va aller
tu veux t'allonger là ?
on peut pas
c'était une blague c'était une blague on peut pas
putin mais c'est la meuf avec sa putin d'arme la putin qui nous a tué 600 fois mec
y a avait son arme posait sur un mur j'avait pas capté
oh bah voilà
bah voilà
putin mec
elle va se faire frapper par l'orage
OOOH !
WTF
ouais c'est bien dit ça
très bien dit
attends c'est dieu qui a envoyé euh...
un *rire* javelot qui l'a transpercé ou quoi enfin une croix l'a transpercé
mon gars incroyable
bon bah salut meuf c'était un plaisire de t'avoir connu
j'était très content de te voir mon gars
y a pas de chemin enfaite Lynn
enfin on est dans une forêt
et tout par en couilles comme tu peux le voir
ouais ça va aller ça va aller
t'inquiète t'inquiète
ouais c'est très bizarre c'est clairement le déluge
DAMN IT
faut qu'on passe dans les flammes ?
non on va faire l'tour
j'me disais ça n'avait aucn sens tu sais
aucun putin de sens
soleil
bientôt fin du monde
bah c'est l'déluge clairement...woooh
très clairement
ouais c'est ce qu'on va faire
aller on fonce on fonce on fonce Lynn on fonce... WOOOH
c'est très très beau c'est petit effets
ça me fait carrément kiffer
aller Lynn "vamos"
on peut l'faire on y est... on y est ça va aller
p'tin on va devoir faire ça sur le bord du ch'min Lynn
allonge toi par terre dans la terre
on va faire ça à la "mano"
truc horrible
aller y faut au moins un matelas un truc là
une baignoire j'sais pas moi
on y est
et ci c'est, c'est encore la maison d'un mec vraiment c'est on a vraiment pas d'chance
ok
oh PUTIN c'est là où l'autre elle s'était holala
c'est quand on s'était réfugier bah ouais le mec avec sa roue derrière et tout...holalalala
ça va aller ça va aller ça va aller
mais qu'est-ce qui ne va pas
qu'est-ce qui va pas
c'est dégueulasse
non !?!
non !!?!!
comment ça y a rien dutout
Lynn
oh nooon putin
c'est déprimant putin
non non !?!
y manquerait plus que Knoth il arrive et là c'est le comble
y a avait pas de cordon ombilical ?
ah ok c'était sa meilleure amie
ok donc c'est ça qui disait juste avant
ho putin
d'accord euh, allons nous en *rire*
mais putin tout ça pour ça
putin Lynn
meuf ça fesait 5h
ho putin c'est horrible
j'sais pas combien... le mec a passait la nuit à te chercher il a vécu les pires truc et il t'retrouve, il a son gosse et toi tu meurs quoi
putiiin
ah ça fait plaisir qu'il fasse jour mec ça fait trop plaisir
incroyable
c'est la fin du jeu
c'est fini putin
oh putin
jusqu'au bout qoui
waaah
très belle la musique
très très beau
le contraste entre le décors et ... putin de merde
le contraste entre le décors et la musique c'est n'importe quoi
Waaah ils ont fait une soirée tout ces gens
d'accord c'est vraiment l'apocalypse
WTF...
le casier
c'est le casier putin
oh non
The END
eh bien les amis n'hésitez pas à aimer ce dernier épisode ci il vous a plu et ci toute la série vous a plu
et ci vous avez aime ce Let's Play c'était ouf putin enfin on a...la fin, la fin du jeu
c'est marrant parce qu'à la fin on est presque plus intéressé enfin on est plus intéressé parce que
par le passé du mec... avec Jessica
que par la situation actuelle où il est dans une secte où y a Lynn on sait pas où
ducoup c'était bel et bien l'hypothèse du prêtre... pédophile, taré... absolument ignoble
c'était un très bon jeu j'trouve qui y a 1h de jeu en trop bizzarement normalement on dit toujours l'inverse
mais j'trouve qui y a vraiment 1h de jeu en trop où c'est toujours d'la poursuite, du j'active, j'esquive j'me cache j'réactive
mais l'histoire est vraiment sympa les décors sont vraiment époustouflant
franchement bravo Red Barrels voila maintenant on aura plus jamais peur
juste s'amuser, rigoler un peu et décompresser
aller merci d'avoir regarder à très bientôt pour de prochaines vidéos... Aurevoir les amis